Yo' what it is?
Sparky Sweets again.
And this week we reppin' down South with
To Kill A Mockingbird by Harper Lee.
This book focuses on three little homies
by the name of Scout,
her crippled brother Jem,
and some homeboy by the name of Dill.
Now, Scout's papa is a righteous lawyer
with the badass name of Atticus.
Since there ain't nothing to do in Alabama,
Scout and her crew spend a summer
harassing a nearby shut-in named Boo Radley.
Now, ain't nobody seen Boo Radley for years.
Scout and her crew try to pass Boo
a note to see if he wants to chill,
but Atticus gets all crunk
and tell dem' kids to "Leave a brother be."
Next day, some little punk steps to Scout...
...and straight up calls Scout's daddy, Atticus, a "Nigger lover."
Mmmm!
Turns out, Atticus has been hired to defend
some ashy playa' named Tom Robinson,
who has been accused of raping
the daughter of a shady cat named Bob Ewell.
At the trial, my boy Atticus spits
mad game up in that court room.
In fact, he discover it was Ewell's daughter
that was puttin' the moves on Tom.
Turns out she wanted some of that
"dark chocolate," know what I mean?
After seeing his daughter
makin' advances on a brotha,
Mr. Ewell smack that bitch up raw,
while Tom peaced out.
But since we talkin' about Alabama here,
them white folks convict him anyway.
Why?
Cuz' he black.
That honky Ewell be pissed that Atticus
made him look like a fool up in court,
so Halloween night, Ewell downs too much of
that juice and gets the drop on Jem and Scout.
Just when he about to rough up my girl, Scout, crazy cracka' Boo Radley comes in outta nowhere,
and shanks that fool. Whoo!
He dead.
Sick and tired of his stupid lip,
the town authorities decide that Ewell
got too drunk and fell on his knife.
Boo gets off Scott free.
Why?
Cuz' icing him, like my girl Scout says,
would be like "Shootin' a mockingbird."
Now, you all don't know sh*t about the title
until you read this here quote on page 90:
Only a jive-ass fool would
pop a cap in a mockingbird,
cuz' all dem bitches do is just drop
next level beats for your enjoyment.
So what my girl, Harper, tryin' to say is that
rattin' on Boo Radley wouldn't do no good.
It only rid the hood of one more true blue playa.
They already done f*cked up once by convictin' Tom,
so they ain't got to pop another mockin' bird.
Now this book right here is a straight up
criticism of the South during The Depression.
The courts, the schools, the church:
all of 'em were run by crooked ass crackas.
Now when we first meet Scout, she's sportin'
all that Southern racism and ignorance.
But after kickin' it with Boo and Tom Rob,
she matures and starts keepin' it real.
Dis' brings to one of the essential
themes of this bitch:
learning valuable lessons by being
exposed to people of difference.
By hangin' with a crazy cracka' like Boo Radley
and a righteous black man like T. Robinson,
Scout has one of them
paradigm shiftin' moments, playa.
She learns that these homies
just be tryin' to hustle like anybody else.
Yo! Check it.
Jim's crippled ass is a metaphor
for America's jacked up justice system.
Jim f*ckin' up his arm so young
be one of them synecdoches
for a country that was born with backward ass ideals.
Now, that sh*t might heal, but it gonna leave
a disabling scar on the nation
and ain't no amount of cocoa butter
gonna make that sh*t go away.
Yo! Thanks for watchin' Thug Notes.
Tune in next week, playa.